journal du côté d'aix en provence il
existe une personne qui s'appelle
monique fayard à l'accueil tous les
week-ends des stagiaires pour une
expérience de découverte de la provence
à travers la peinture on se retrouve
bien évidemment au bas de la montagne
sainte-victoire jacques cardoze avec
jean-paul chaussée la lumière déjà
présent c'est le début d'un week-end
dominé par les couleurs un stage de
peinture en extérieur face à la lumière
réelle telle qu'elle est et non pas
telle qu'elle est représentée sur photo
monique fayard commence donc ses cours
par une visite d'aix-en-provence le
lendemain rendez-vous est pris à l'ombre
des marronniers devant l'atelier premier
apprentissage avant de partir sur les
traces de sésame certaines mesures parce
que ce qu'on parte n surmonté
on se retrouve avec un dosage depuis
hier km m 55
voilà donc un prétexte au plaisir voire
la région célèbre notamment pour ceux ci
la montagne sainte victoire
aujourd'hui un couple d'américains une
brésilienne une aixoise ont décidé de se
lancer un défi
imiter l'illustrent qu'un alors je veux
savoir que cette victoire ponctuée d'un
faux pas rapidement parce qu'avec la
lumière elle change parce que les formes
et de couleurs c'est sur gris bleu une
véritable course contre la montre
commence
une difficulté autant pour les amateurs
que pour paul cézanne avant de saisir
cette lumière qui métamorphose les
couleurs season 6 en effet repris à 70
fois
voilà qui laisse un peu d'espoir
tellement changeant ce qu'on peut jamais
s'en lasser ses pairs le plus grand
plaisir qu'on peut avoir
cézanne est l'un de mes héros comme van
gogh ou matisse être ici c'est comme
vivre dans un tableau
c'est bien connu ce qui est
insaisissable attire pas question pour
autant de faire du cézanne en deux jours
ce stage se limite au plaisir celui des
yeux ce n'est déjà pas si mal